واحدة من أولى القصص التي يتم سردها
واحد لنا في فلسطين
أمر إخواننا
اسمي نوردان الباميا اينجي ، متزوج 36
عمري ولدت في Muş في اسطنبول
لقد نشأت ودرست المدرسة في اسطنبول
دخلت قسم المسرح الموسيقي
قرأت
[موسيقى]
إيصال قصص المظلومين إلى المسرح
أشعر بمهمة حول وضع
أنا بنفسي كنت أعزف منذ 13 عامًا و
بالطبع كنت في أكثر من 1000 مرحلة
أجمل مستمعي القصص الخيالية دائمًا
كان الأطفال أحبك أكثر الطيور
لا تدعه يسمع كما أريد دائما
مسرحية عن القضية الفلسطينية
أردت أن أفعل ذلك ، لقد كان محظوظًا العام الماضي.
لقد مر عام بخصوص فلسطين
ألعب لعبة تسمى يجب أن نتحدث
لقد كتبت حوالي 50 لمدة عام
لعبنا مرة واحدة
بالطبع ، جزء معين من لعبتنا في فلسطين
نحن أيضا نكسب دخلا ولكن بالفعل
جزء كبير من عائداتنا
نحن نرسل الجزء إلى فلسطين.
لأخواتنا المرابي في الحضانة
في نفس الوقت أرسل الدروس
أنا أكسب رزقي بإلقاء المحاضرات
انا اوفر حمزة
يا اريد فلسطين كثيرا
دع الأطفال يتعلمون القضية أولاً هذا الصيف.
سوف ندرسه بعد ذلك
العام المقبل سواء عن فلسطين
كان يجب أن نتحدث ولعبة أطفالنا
سنلعب آمل لكنك لا تفعل
تذكر ، كانت هناك مريم
دعني أخبرك أن المفتاح قد عهد إليك